let me ask you my friend as last
question what happened to you here
where did i pass my head something here
red on on the right on the right here
have i done this all into beat
after years of playing james bond on the
big screen daniel craig doesn't even
notice his injuries anymore not even
when he's bleeding from the head during
a 25-minute sit-down interview i'm very
quite embarrassed now and can't look you
in the face during variety's actor on
actors series the 53 year old actor was
shocked to learn he had been bleeding
the whole time he was chatting with his
skyfall co-star javier bardem take a
look at your mirror
what is that you know what it was christ
i didn't even look at it so
they've sent me this this wonderful ring
flash which i've set up with an ipad in
the middle of it and i went like this
like that and it just fell on my head
just before it
yeah so it turns out double07's biggest
nemesis yet is a ring light stand and an
ipad this is going to be my last one i
think someone else should have a go
back in october after over a decade
portraying the iconic role daniel took
his final bow with the fifth installment
of his run as bond in no time to die
we all have our secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet i'm very
proud of what we've done i'm so
so lucky to have been sort of had this
this opportunity for the past 16 years
and sometimes it was a slog it's gone
like that it's just it's you know i i'm
i remember being announced as james bond
like it was yesterday leading up to his
final bond films premiere the action
star reflected on his time as the secret
agent during a sit down with e.t
i've changed
immeasurably since i began this in my
professional life and in my personal
life clearly it's given me
a
um
a confidence that i didn't have when i
started off this confidence to sort of
try and
make the best
of what you have and make the best
movies we can and that's all i ever ever
wanted out of this
okay but back to that whole bleeding
from the head thing according to daniel
he's pretty accident prone so the whole
incident didn't exactly shock him
this is 17 years playing bombed can you
see the throne
no wonder i get [ __ ] injured every
time i do a movie
well it showed
jesus christ i'm not bleeding today it's
just all right all right whatever
if i don't get injured while i'm filming
it's i'm not doing it properly well
that's one way to look at it and he
wasn't wrong back in 2019 daniel injured
his ankle on the set of the action flick
and had to have surgery
i had a a very good surgeon so he
basically um
wired it all back together again so it
was fine but all's well that ends well
and as his time as bond came to an end
his no time to die co-stars couldn't
help but gush to et over his epic run as
the legendary character i've just really
enjoyed watching him um
take on the responsibility of this thing
and kind of grow into it he's just
rocked it it's emotional because it is
daniel's last film and he gave so much
you know for this character he gave 15
years of his life i'm a huge fan of
daniels i wanted this to be a really
special send-off for him and i think we
accomplished that